hi I'm Rohit kevlani I just got
naturalized today I'm officially a U.S
citizen now
I'm super excited to be participating in
the voting process this time around
my name is Maureen Cruz and I voted in
every election that I've been eligible
for that's since 1970. I think if you
look at globally there's a lot going on
right now right we already see the oil
prices sort of shooting up we see all
the Russia Ukraine war going on at the
same time China trying to become a
Supercar we have multiple problems
people don't have a living wage housing
prices are you know skyrocketing the
counterpart homes
student debt that's an outrage it's an
outrage we see the inflation rates
through the roof so for us as families
it's becoming harder and harder to
sustain a decent livelihood we also see
that and we're hearing a lot about
recession coming but there's been really
a Devolution of the quality of life for
people in this country and I think
that's why people are on edge you
wouldn't have January 6th if people felt
comfortable in their lives end of the
day we are a democracy we all should be
abiding by the law and the Constitution
and when there are individuals who sort
of try to become more and above the
Constitution I think it's it's dangerous
to any democracy people are feeling
disrespected
and they are
our government has been disrespecting
people
and we need to get back to respecting
our Humanity